there's a guy across the street vote for
his brothers got killed one of them got
gunned down in a gas station that I used
to run with it they gunned him down and
it's funny because we just left it and
he went to the gas station to get gas
and his name McDonald and then his other
brother which is an older guy he got
killed
Oh dirt he did his big brother and he's
all I got left
he's basically like family to me from
the same neighborhood I am we holds one
another Road me and I go over there not
to talk to him
and every day I fear because the game
thing it's like when you try to get out
over some games you went through for
life Manning it and you have the young
kids you know that's coming up and it's
this way totally different than what
really really worth when we was in gangs
that's up you know getting initiated see
we had a lot of deaths all through the
70s and the 90s all I did I went to more
funerals than I did parties and I had to
bury my own brother and today yes very I
walk around I see gang members I find
myself getting in the middle of
conversations with him it's like you
know to say you guys cuz it's like today
I'll see you tomorrow you ain't even
here and it happens that quick even down
here and it's just like what happened to
the limits the the boundaries done what
happened to the guys they're supposed to
be looking over us man and these kids
man you know God let this happen to this
kid I let this happen to this kid and
you know like when I was coming up to
get in the game you have to take a swill
excuse my language but you gotta take a
ass-whooping and you have to prove
yourself that's the way it really worth
and you have to be loyal
you can't lie if they found that if you
went to prison and said well look man
street i was doing this i was doing that
i got a 65 shitty you get took down for
lying
you know they stay loyal to the game if
you did something bad anything that you
do it's gonna catch your bite you an ass
kids end up in prison with release dates
like today is 2020
they released agus 2069 either young
kids for gang banging just took a pop
shot at or somebody that could have been
the best friend 2069 3016 depr DS which
mean this is the earliest possible
release date you can get out when I
started going to prison in my day they
already told me there's only three ways
Commodore that you can get up out of
here
wise a homosexual or in the boxes show
choice believe me a lot of guys turned
into three Nate you know I tell these
guys now they if they can see the future
is so many opportunities out here on the
street not I wish I can even go back
even though I have my freedom but I
still don't have the pride that I used
to have I still fear teens and when I
walk it's like somebody call my name hey
Commodore you think they're ready to get
at your program you know there's some
opportunities out here man it's like if
I had if I had it my way man I'm telling
you I guess I could save you some things
I can help to people you know so I just
only tell people you know what man
before you die even my own friends cuz
you can see it coming tell young guys
alright man if they don't want to listen
just a minute just get you do yourself a
favor and get safe you know hopefully
you might go to have it you know you
know there's guys walking around right
now and they me they don't like they old
cheese they figure they can get strikes
by knocking the old cheese there's gangs
turning on gangs gangs fighting one
another like my game you know originally
I'm originally from ludus Park I'm 58
years old today thank God
and if y'all can here it is you know
i'ma tell you I just like this man he
meant had a Nintendo game getting a
grill gang the church game getting an
organization that's helping others you
know
[ __ ] is old man the cemetery is
overcrowded just from nineteen eighty to
eighty six one cemetery one funeral home
3060 something deaths and that was just
all gang-related you know it's just a
lot of sadness going around here it's
just like the love [ __ ] stripped from
people I understand your name even in
youngsters heart like he used to be but
i'ma tell you just like this though
being buff selling weed selling dope
being young hitting who man is just so
many opportunities there's so much to do
out there man and I would tell all the
youngsters men and young girls man I see
the face down here every day we break
them up you know they really want to
kill one another we job we lost a few
youngsters around the corner guy gets
shot in the back by a girl
lady shot and killed you know seriously
this is not the life you want because
once you go to prison man that's your
wake-up call
the cold thing about a yelling I getting
out we had a chance so take the
opportunity today man and do what you
have to do man and and you know I'll see
you I'll see you if you come downtown
I'm gonna see I'm gonna ask up out of
here you know I don't even want to be
here this is not the life that you want
you know maybe a lowrider you know you
take a little ride every time you and I
like [ __ ] bestow you know ain't nothing
wrong with starving you know ain't
nothing wrong with being GQ but if you
watching this though man that gang sign
she didn't even gonna work there was a
guy I could tell you a young man that
got killed and he was mute he was only
commuting to a gay communicating to
another guy across the street doing his
hands and somebody misconstrues to head
in thought he was throwing up gang signs
because he did his fingers the wrong way
and this little kid got shot he was only
communicating with his friend across the
street telling him to come get you you
know it's just this is crazy and that's
just not the life that I want to live
this is not nothing I want to live so if
I can give back I'd like to take this
opportunity man I'll go
I talk to people I help people I try to
get it back because I don't want God to
be ashamed of me I want to be somebody
in my life I ain't gonna be here much
longer you know but I'm gonna enjoy my
moments man I mean Joey trying to speak
to people and encourage every so I can
say I did mine before it's all over with
you know I grew up I was not it just so
messed up in gangs man I went to drugs
you know I take it high let's go shoot
somebody you know it's just let's go
fight somebody be surprised man dynamite
coming small package just to I had I had
a good record weightlifting 153 pounds
bench pressing 440 maxing it out you
know so that's just even pumped my evil
look even bigger you know guys we try to
get at me I mean I had that punch that
he just set you down but anything that
in the break above them and if I can
take things back man it'd be a lot of
people still live if I wouldn't I did
the dumbest [ __ ] it would have been a
lot of people still living if I had to
turn my back on a lot of people they'll
still be living when people would say
reaching out to help me looking for that
encouragement I didn't even comprehend
that at the time they will still be
living you know I'm telling you it's not
easy man it's just uh it's just woke up
on you you know and it's just it's a lot
of young people the schools is basically
empty I wish I had opportunities like we
do go to trade takes get paid just go to
school man just to learn something
teacher dumbass there's something better
than what you're doing you know I care
less about a game man it was cool when
you was in it but telling you man when
you get behind the gun man and shoot
somebody that experience is not what you
want you know that shoot take somebody's
life it's not what you want you know we
do what we do but is that's not that's
not what's happening that's not so
boring oh man make mama proud
make yourself proud do something with
your life you don't have a life man [ __ ]
I'm trying to get my bag
you know I did give my high school
diploma so do yourself a favor get your
GED I'll get a high school diploma man
get educated man be smart man he's smart
man could [ __ ] out of the next people to
take over man give us a better way man I
don't want nobody whooping my ass in the
convalescent home
see that's just gonna get old and I'm
gonna be old in a minute ain't gonna be
Commodore no more maybe that bandage I
thought about all this dude used to be
me and not I still want to be when that
time comes I want to go out happy you
know I want to make my sister now you
know somebody that told me they were
looking at this and they see me and they
say Commodore we like what you said and
they know I'm a freak the truth I'm
gonna be real it makes me be proud of
something and it motivates me to keep
going to keep going be make them listen
make the ladies listen man I had so many
phone calls then now I'm my equal it's
up bad you know Commodores back but I'm
back in a positive way to tell y'all
something man you know what she did
ain't no light in the darkness
it ain't no such thing it's no such
thing as I'm a cellar gang a dope I'm a
gangbang man and I say the next year I'm
gonna do that no such thing as next year
it ain't none of that [ __ ] you know the
prisons love you they love people that
don't even think you know Rachel suffer
letter write yourself a letter to
yourself and write yourself a letter to
that man upstairs and thinking what you
know that he will tell you his response
and then you can see what how your
attitude be and you'd be surprised with
coming out your mouth I mean you would
come out your heart which you would
really be which you would really feel
it's like you don't have to pay for your
friendship I know how growing up can be
I was little I feel the only are the
only way that I can fit in our pan for
my friendship for health I was being
working I'm the only one coming around
spending money buying beer doing this
then they tried to introduce me to drugs
put a pipe in my mouth they told me this
[ __ ] to do right here and they should've
doing and you're here next thing you
know man I did I get a system over 30
years you know and it's no fun in it
thank God I'm out here today so I would
like to encourage people man you must
sell
every day so when I crawl out my bed and
touched my knees on the floor I'm gonna
stay there for a minute I'm gonna thank
God for another day and I'm gonna keep
on man I'm gonna just be ready for my
date man I'm just the type of person
that worried about my day that's what
gang members do when we walk out the
house man we just tell god man I hope
don't happen to me today you know
because it's out there people recognize
you you know that gang stuff is not
gonna get it that's now I don't care
were you from it's not gonna get it the
war is still on man but let's break that
war down you know let's do it let's do
some things that we need to do you know
if you're young come on baby I'll let
your boy man I don't care where you from
you know it ain't no blood coming up out
of my mouth I know where I'm originally
from I made it I made it through the
storm
you know storm was just a big old
squirrel believe me but I held on to my
nuts a lot of people lost theirs so you
know this [ __ ] is real that's all I can
tell you man that's really real man I
wish out the best I like to see people
pulling because well we like waking up
in the morning watching people go to
school and work that was motivate me it
was just like that man who won a lottery
ticket you know he's just stood on this
balcony and just laughed man because
when you get in your 30s and you didn't
did everything you're supposed to do
believe me you gonna have every reason
to smile instead of waiting on a 30
pound box you know what I'm saying
somebody sent me a package who don't
send me some money my girl is [ __ ]
this - excuse my language but don't
worry about that you know take your time
get educated educate yourself
don't don't don't make the mistakes we
did don't make the mistakes my friend
did most of the people from us said they
really stood boil they stayed loyal to
the game and I'm gonna tell you I still
a remix I had they hook up I would get
in touch with a man because that's where
I come from I can't speak on another sis
but where I come from you gotta be
honest to the game I twisted you know
are you gonna lose your life even right
now today I can lose my my mind feels
lip right now and I couldn't even
probably walk out this door and it goes
just like this so yeah I worry you know
that tongue it's a cold sward man you
can twist people look you can see
somebody's shivering a minute you know I
look back on the things that we did and
I look at how these youngsters doing it
they say sloppy man y'all don't need to
do [ __ ] like this you know go slumming
the front doing go out the back y'all
don't need to do that but I'm tell you
the prisons there's no place to be they
got a lot of prison and any like they
used to be they don't even feel like
they used to be they don't even have
weights you can't smoke a cigarette you
know only thing you're gonna do is
stress and that one of them dudes I'm
officers kill you up in there and they
still get any banging in there
everything a kitchen but one thing after
five years you realize you're not
getting out because your release date is
5080 you know I never phone get out and
that's the type of time they're handing
out I think I could tell you my name is
Commodore Manning I just I wish I were
the best man peace
you